[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream I am here with dr.
Heather huiying this is our 26th
livestream I believe and the first time
that you've had a new haircut yes this
is my first post kovat haircut and my
barber seems to have not weathered the
economic storm so I don't know for sure
that they failed but they may have so I
was forced to go through the rather
traumatic experience of establishing a
relationship with a new hair person
which is always fraught for me because I
have such troubling hair that there's
always room for a major mistake your
hair is not troubling other people are
troubled other people well yes point
taken in any case I went in and I had
the same interaction that I always had
which is I I try to warn them I said I
have very very difficult hair and the
person becomes effusive and they say no
you have marvelous hair and I know
they're lying and here's how I know
because at the end if you hang around
after you've paid they sweep it off the
floor and they just throw it away
yeah no that's definitely about you yes
yeah I mean they don't do that to anyone
else I guess I put them in an awkward
position by raising the issue but yeah
they don't tell you the truth I'm
supposed to know
all right well things keep happening
have you noticed that I have yeah it's
it's quite a world out there so we're
gonna try to unpack what is it taking
place yeah you have a place you want to
start oh we can start by talking a
little bit about schools of Education
which is something I alluded to either
last time or the time before as you like
I thought that would be in the middle
but okay you're gonna start there yeah
okay so I had alluded to a friend of
ours Lyle
Asher who is a professor associate
professor full professor I don't member
which of English at Lewis & Clark
College right here in Portland wrote an
article in 2018 I think it was for the
Chronicle of Higher Education
which is really the original and
preeminent what are you doing okay which
is the original and preeminent Chronicle
journal for people in higher ed mostly
for administrators but many of us who
have been academics have been reading it
and he later because I was behind a
paywall did publish this in Aquila as
well so it's available without a paywall
let me just walk us through a little bit
of what his argument is and they were
gonna show a clip that was sent to us by
another friend of ours Mike Nina who was
doing extraordinary work in this regard
- so one of what his basic argument is
schools of higher education schools of
Education which our training have
historically trained teachers of k-12
students K through 12 students have no
history of excellence they have their
their famously not excellent ever every
moment that people have gone looking but
that more recently they have begun to
train not just teachers of children but
also administrators of colleges and
universities and not just administrators
of schools of Ed themselves but
administrators across the board so one
of the foundational papers in the
so-called scholarship in this realm that
has become really foundational for many
in schools of Education is on my core
microaggressions and in this paper is so
rife with sleight of hands sleight of
hand and so void of critical thinking
it's remarkable it was written by seven
academics at various schools of
Education or maybe it was all at one and
here's just a quote from this paper that
Asher takes two pieces they say again
this is the foundational is sort of the
introduction of the concept of
microaggressions from if memory serves
maybe a 2014 paper micro aggressive acts
can usually be explained away by
seemingly non biased and valid reasons
for the recipient of a microaggression
however there is always the nagging
question of whether it really happened
it is difficult to identify a
microaggression especially when other
explanations seem plausible many people
of color describe a vague
they have been attacked they have been
disrespected or that something is not
right microaggressions operate to create
psychological dilemmas for both the
white perpetrator and the person of
color so Asher quotes this from this
paper and says why is everyone falling
for this kind of thinking which
explicitly pits villains against victims
it creates it creates exactly the
dynamic that is pretending to be
fighting against and he says why are
people not pushing back against this
garbage so just one quote here from him
he says because doing so yeah why not
why not tear apart
such clearly divisive pseudo scholars
scholarly thinking he says because doing
so would derail a deep nostalgia not of
course for the overt brutality and
dehumanization fled to by Jim Crow and
the likes of Bull Connor but for the
moral certainty those evils which
respectively allow for in some respects
people of color may find an overt an
obvious racist act easier to handle the
essay that he's talking about obligingly
develops a crude alchemy for transmuting
the ambiguous into the obvious this
alchemy is little more than a way of
behaving that masquerades as a way of
knowing act as if ambiguities were
certainties and as a vague feelings for
reliable registers effect act in other
words as if complex interracial
encounters which admit of both mistakes
and misunderstandings are conscious or
unconscious acts of racism exercised by
a quote white perpetrator that will
indeed make things easier to handle
Asher says one more from Asher but such
ease of handling is the product of
presumption and simplification it would
be as if a marriage counselor approached
every new couple having decided in
advance that the complaints or
suspicions of the shorter partner or the
male partner or the minority partner
were necessarily legitimate and then the
other spouses objections prejudged as
defensive were evidence of guilt
moreover because these objections would
in the author's pseudo technical jargon
invalidate the experiential reality of
the other partner that is offer
different point of view they would
constitute yet another offense would
anyone expect marital relations to
improve under such a counselor
supervision would anyone even hire such
a counselor
now you'd be crazy too you'd be crazy
too and this so really I but cannot
recommend this essay highly enough it's
it's so it's so good and I don't know if
we want to go right into this little
piece of video or you want to say some
things about what what you just heard
well I would agree with you Lyle has
been on this case for quite some time
and reading his work is very sobering
because he just cuts right to the heart
of it those quotes are excellent and
really point to it but what I'm hoping
people will do is they will start to
think about what the architecture that
is built up around these claims becomes
and what it looks like going forward
because of course the thing that you've
been saying for quite some time is that
as this moves into the schools of Eady
it obviously moves into the children and
it moves into the children and therefore
cannot help but pervade society because
where do the children go absolutely
everywhere right so anyway that's sure
to be a theme of much of our discussion
today but let's look at that clip yeah
so before before you put the clip up
sack when I mentioned this essay a
couple of episodes ago Mike Nina who
many of you will recognize the name as
the director and producer of the
excellent three-part documentary on the
Evergreen Fiasco it's in a yna you can
find him on YouTube here sent me the
following clip and it is from let me see
it is a clip from an organization called
se creates which is an acronym creates
as an acronym that stands for culturally
responsive environments attaining
transformative equitable solutions let's
just watch this minute or so long clip
yes I creates is that an amazing
opportunity for our school to have time
dedicated to come together to talk about
how do we create anti-racist schools I
see
teaching as a very political act when we
are engaging with our students whether
it's on social justice issues or
multicultural issues or culturally
relevant teaching I see that as
foundational to all learning we are
learning a lot about like different
issues in this world
and like um what's happening around like
we're mostly thinking about like racial
and culture in my class and how we can
change the future we have all of these
different people that are activists we
have gay people we have transgendered
people and we have people that are
taking action and we're learning how to
take action in social studies now we've
seen our students become empowered we've
seen them see that even at the age of
four that they can take an active role
and be activists and so it's through
this work that we realize that education
without this conversation isn't gonna
make a difference for our children even
for ural even four-year-olds bretton
even four-year-olds could be activists
even for yes and so what's so disturbing
as an educator and of course I never
taught young kids but as an educator I
know and from being a parent I know kids
have to have and they have to be
trusting in order for education to be
effective because they don't have the
tools to be discerning and to choose
between the truth and lies if they have
a teacher that's spouting both of them
they can't detect which witch is which
and so anyway you would expect evolution
to have built children to be trusting
and that the it is the obligation of the
adults around them to protect them from
untruths and when the adults around them
start spouting on trees feeding them
fictions in an effort to turn them into
soldiers in some battle that they will
ultimately join it's just an incredible
betrayal of of their natural role as
educators and mentors the natural
betrayal by the teachers by the teachers
and the administrators and coming down
from on high from the schools of Ed and
you know it
it misunderstands so much about what
humans are and about what children are
right one thing that most people who are
professional educators in k-12 schools
and probably in higher ed as well don't
know and probably would tell you the
exact opposite if you were to ask them
is that school not only isn't a thing
that exists outside of humans but it's
not a human Universal by any means
learning is and every social organism
out there be they human or not does some
learning but the idea of school in which
you have an authority who hands down
information as opposed to the young
interactively learning by observing and
doing is really not just a modern but
specifically a we're a pretty weird that
is to say you know Western educated
industrialized rich democratic society
weird that acronym and surely there are
other there are non weird countries that
have that have school but it's it's a
bit of a bastardization of the honest
and necessary thing that we need as
children which is to be actively
observing engaging doing learning and to
have that that software hijacked by
activists educators is is an abomination
the software is hijacked for
indoctrination purposes so what I think
is probably true to see if you agree is
that mentoring is absolutely Bic WA
tusen humans that schooling is a an
alternative to mentoring and it opens
the door to indoctrination right
mentoring is inherently I believe free
of it because at some level if you're
showing somebody how to do something
they will immediately detect that you
are telling them nonsense because what
you're demonstrating how to do won't
work as well as it does when you don't
do whatever the nonsense was so we've
opened the door to this with formal
schooling and then we see this thing
migrated into the schools of ed now I am
sure that most of our viewers will be in
the same boat that I was in until
recently having thought almost nothing
whatsoever about schools of Education
right what even is a School of Education
what does it cover so in some sense we
are all living downstream of a
phenomenon that touches all of these
teachers who then reach all of these
kids who then show up in our college
classrooms and we have no idea the kids
them
have no idea where a lot of the
structure in their belief system even
came from in this case it's like it's a
kind of developmental gatekeeping and
the I think the effect that it is having
on the present is that people are
misunderstanding where we are in history
that they are watching what is taking
place in the street and almost always
when I talk to people about it I have
the sense that they are too calm because
they think we are much earlier in the
process than we actually are and what's
going on is that they are modeling the
idea of revolution based on what I would
call a vertical revolution you know so
Fidel Castro and Che Guevara and a small
band of people team up and they reside
in the hills and they come down and they
make dramatic strikes and they win over
the population and ultimately they
topple the governmental structure that's
not the kind of revolution we're facing
at the moment what we are facing is a
horizontal resolution where ideas have
been inserted into so many minds that
exist in every organization that what
we're going to see is instance after
instance in which suddenly the thing
awakens almost like a sleeper cell
inside of every journalistic body inside
every business inside every you know
it's already been spotted in
universities but the point is where
isn't it in a position to take over
frankly I think it's even in a position
to take the presidency in two moves
right I think that's coming do you do
you want to speak to what those two
moves are well sure I mean maybe maybe
it has to be a little deeper down in our
discussion of what's going on but if you
imagine that you've got this wrongheaded
belief system unfalsifiable wrongheaded
belief system so this is like a new
religion it's a religion but it doesn't
even have the claim on being valid by
virtue of having stood the test of time
this is brand new so it's myth it's
mythology that's marching through every
institution we
when it becomes activated those who
operate it are in a position to dictate
terms to anybody who might resist and so
each institution topples so that
horizontal revolution is taking place
because every individual is going to be
faced with the same puzzle which is I am
personally in jeopardy I'm in no
position to do anything that will
effectively repel this onslaught but I
am in a position to silence it and it's
accusations against me for the moment by
delivering some apology or offering it's
something that it's demanding you know
it will succeed in capturing more and
more people well but even even before
that comes you have people who have
legitimate grievances because as we've
talked about many and many previous
episodes the you know beginning yes we
as Gen Xers also inherited a moment when
the economy was not booming particularly
but not hmm
Millennials inherited a worst moment by
far and they're in debt and have low
chance of getting real estate and you
know having good health care and all of
these things and so they have real
grievances despite what some would say
they actually have real grievances and
they have been handed a pro forma
explanation for what is it the base of
those grievances even when the proform
explanation actually would seem to do
nothing to address any of the actual
grievances they're out there but it
feels righteous and honorable and
finally a cause that they can get behind
and feel good and like their lives have
meaning for standing up for something
and all of those things it's sort of a
perfect storm that gets people out on
the streets especially after being in
lockdown for months right and then once
once they've done it once they've stood
up and held a placard and shouted in
March it's very much harder to say hmm
I'm not sure that's actually what I met
or I'm not sure that it is what it said
it meant and therefore I'm not sure that
I should have stood up for that thing
right yeah it's much harder once once
you have stood stood with a movement
to distance yourself from that movement
and of course this is a long known
psychological trick that is utilized by
the most effective regimes that you
don't that the thing that wishes you ill
will ill does not tend to come down with
a hammer and beat you up in front of
your loved ones that's not how it's done
it does so by incrementally changing
what it is that you say that you believe
such that incrementally you change what
you do actually believe yeah it gets
harder and harder to deprogram and it's
actually very much a cult phenomenon
right once you once you've gotten in on
the ground floor it's very hard to get
out and you see this man this is why you
know in the last episode I we were
sharing those pictures that I had taken
in Southwest Portland and you know the
business that had its windows plastered
you know that I call the don't hurt me
wall well every probably fifth window in
an area with apartment buildings and
anything you know anything beyond just
retail on the ground floor every fifth
window or so has a black lives matter
poster in it and if you say something
about that to any random person on the
street they are going to immediately
conflate any critique of that suggesting
groupthink with a critique of the very
idea that lower case lower case lower
case black lives matter of course they
do yeah yeah we saw the same thing at
Evergreen with the flyer gate scenario
where the campus found itself actually
publishing flyers that claimed white
supremacy was widespread at Evergreen
which it simply wasn't but everybody was
putting them up doing you know
advertising we're your friend and the
point is that is actually evidence of
how much power is gained very quickly by
this horizontal revolution so here's the
part that I think people don't get yet
why is the Democratic Party playing ball
all right it would seem that the
Democratic Party ought to be attempting
to establish some sort of reason and to
calm the situation when in fact what
it's doing is signing on to this very
dangerous set of beliefs so before you
go on why does it seem that the
Democratic Party should be trying to
calm the situation why would you that
you just asserted that yeah and some you
have some peep
audience will say yeah like they should
be obviously and some people will said
well of course I've never done it why
would they so why why does it seem that
they should be doing something that
they're not before we get on to why
they're doing the thing that they are
well it seems that they should be
because a large part of their natural
constituency are white people who aren't
actually guilty of racism and therefore
need a defense and even if the
Democratic Party was being cynical you
would think they would defend a large
number of people in need of a defense
and you know be trying to hold their
coalition together which involves lots
of people of color and lots of white
people and just trying not to let that
thing fray but here's what people don't
get first of all as I've said elsewhere
these two parties are deeply corrupt
they are both involved in intense
influence peddling so policy does not
mirror the needs of the population
almost ever anymore in general it is
serving some other interest in it is
dressed up to look like it is for the
people and therefore the people begin to
detect that they are frozen out of
well-being they get angry they spill
into the streets now here's the problem
the elites the economic elites who are
represented by these two parties do not
wish to share the well-being and
opportunity that they are hoarding right
they have hoarded these things that was
the purpose of their investing in these
corrupt entities and they don't want to
share so what can they do well wait the
corrupt entities that you're referring
to that the two parties has been
invested well no the parties have
invested in the corrupt entities I
thought you said no parties have a
racket the racket is to gain power by
appealing to voters enough to get
elected and then to peddle the influence
that they win at the ballot box to their
actual constituents which are powerful
elites that keep the entities afloat so
they don't want to share power
they now have something that looks a lot
like the French Revolution in the
streets and although various people at
the New York Times may think that's cool
those of us who know anything about the
French Revolution know how dangerous
this is so what are they going to do
well they're not going to share what
they've hoarded and the street isn't in
a and a mindset to to wait any longer
right it's boiled over enough is enough
so what's happened is the blue corrupt
entity has decided in time but not the
police the Democrats yes the democratic
party sorry blue versus red the blue
corrupt entity has come up with a plan
which is they are going to divert the
resent the resentment that naturally
should go to them for hoarding the
opportunity in the first place they're
going to redirect that resentment at
people who superficially can be
demonized if you imagine that racism is
in every whitehead and there's nothing
that can be done about it and it
pervades the thoughts of white people
and is therefore in every interaction
and every decision and all of those
things then you might say yeah it is
that's the reason that we're we're not
succeeding is that those people are
always having racist thoughts that they
never voice but nonetheless it's it's
the reason that we can't get anywhere
rather than somebody took all of the
opportunity and frankly the whole
population of normal people is suffering
from the reduction in available
opportunity but by redirecting the anger
of people who can identify that they're
actually on the list of people who's
going to get something right they can
the elites can stave off the French
Revolution coming for them in other
words they're going to redirect the
French Revolution at somebody else
somebody who can't defend themselves and
that's white people of regular means so
that thing is yet one more ploy to to
prevent the actual reckoning that comes
from hoarding all of the opportunity but
what it means in this case the two-step
plan to take the white house we've got
not your plan oh and our plan their plan
their plan in is going to involve this
old codger that they have set up for
nomination decrepit Klan Biden the
decrepit clown Joe Biden is of course
going to nominate Camilla Harris as VP
because of course it's That moment when
certain demographic parameters have to
be met Kamala Harris is like the living
breathing DNC that's what she is and
then DNC being the Democratic National
the Democratic National Committee which
is different than the party many of us
are still member
the party but anybody with half a brain
has no tolerance for what the DNC has
done to the party but Kamala Harris ends
up on the ticket maybe Joe Biden wins
because people are so fed up with Trump
which they are and then Joe Biden steps
down at some point right
Kamala Harris then would be president by
virtue of having been brought on the
ticket for symbolic largely symbolic
reasons it's not like people are wildly
in favor of her and then there it is
then the intersectional madness has made
a deal with somebody who would inhabit
the role of the president now of course
there is another way this could all go
down which is that the white folks who
understand that they have been targeted
in a way that would traditionally have
been pointed at Jews maybe but in this
case it's going to be white folks writ
large they may decide not to let this
happen and my biggest fear is I've been
saying I went back and found a video on
my channel that I'd put out in 2019
saying look they're gonna conjure
exactly the white supremacist demon that
they claim to be fighting right now by
backing white people against the wall
and getting them to identify as some
sort of natural entity at the very least
it's going to push more such people into
voting for Trump in November and those
that demographic shift will be observed
in the in the voting polls presumably
and that will be trotted out as evidence
that the only reason to vote for Trump
in the first place was because you were
racist all along so it is this they are
creating a self-fulfilling prophecy
whether and without any reference to
whether or not there was truth there to
begin with
yeah and it's it's clear to me that what
needs to happen is voices of reason who
get the nuance here it's not that the
resentment isn't real and it's not that
the gripe isn't well-founded it is
well-founded but it is not well
articulated and the proposals that are
being suggested are
insane I mean it's hard to give them
more credit than that they're just
literally insane proposals that nobody
who had ever run anything of any size
could possibly imagine we're going to
make things better
all right society evaporating is going
to be a disaster for all of us so
somebody needs to step in and speak to
the movement about what it is that has
them angry and what actual remedies
might look like which does involve
taking a good look at the elites who
have hoarded the opportunity and
figuring out what to do to bry it loose
from them mm-hmm so you said that I'm
actually I'm not sure to pronounce her
name I thought it was Kamala Harris but
you said that she is the living
breathing embodiment of the DNC I think
and I'm wondering what that surprises me
a little bit because she strikes me as
sort of half the living breathing a body
man at the DNC but I admit that I have
probably a very shaky understanding of
exactly what that is I feel like a
change during the Clinton era quite
substantially and you know the the
Clinton one era in the 90s but that
she's equally and you know this is these
are coming to converge on one eye there
but that she is equally embedded in woke
intersectional ideology and I think the
DNC has come to adopt that as one of its
foundational planks but it wasn't it
wasn't the platform at least until
recently this is exactly what I'm saying
okay I don't believe that this is I mean
who's to even say you can't detect the
difference between genuine
intersectional misunderstanding and
cynical embrace of intersectional ism
because it advances your your ball but
what she is is the it's the Chimera
right you have the DNC serves to it is
the center of the influence-peddling
operation and therefore the blue half of
that I'll wrap the blue racquet yeah so
the blue racquet is run through the DNC
the DNC therefore has to figure out some
sort of you know is there enough
symbolism that we can hand people that
will keep them voting for us so that we
have influence that we can peddle that's
the game right
well oh the symbolism thing has now run
out on them
gonna have to give them something real
we're gonna have to give them something
that tastes like food and well-being
where are we gonna get that if we're not
willing to share what we have and what
our constituents have hoarded we're
gonna have to look at somebody else who
can't defend theirs and feed that to
them and so this is this I mean this
actually back to Asher's point about the
entire ideology one of creating an
us-versus-them dynamic of creating
victims and victimizers oppressed and
oppressors that this is this is an easy
way to rile people up and to get people
motivated out on the streets out to the
polls you know you're on the right side
of history you know they're not you have
to get rid of those people because they
are evil well there are two things here
yes that's the sense right that's the
more honorable sense but the real I
think that's there's nothing honorable
about that at all it's not it's not
honorable
but it's the more honor occasion so my
point would be look the reason I invoke
Jews here is that because of the nature
of the Jewish Diaspora because you have
a small population that does well but
tends to live amongst people to whom it
is less well related than Jews are to
each other
you can always when things go wrong
point to the Jews and you can say they
are the problem now are the Jews really
the problem no but that doesn't matter
because if you're really willing to
steal what they have and hand it to
somebody else
it's a classic transfer frontier to use
our language right it's a it's a source
for something that feels like growth
that you can hand to somebody else to
placate them and my point is that's
always cynical garbage in this case
there's a twist which is that you have
an intersectional coalition this is not
a natural coalition it is a it is a
synthetic coalition that is going to be
fed the well-being of a natural entity
right European Americans now
the point is that actually from the
point of view of solving the problem
that the influence-peddling rackets face
if you try to put yourself in their
mindset right how do we keep this going
for another electoral cycle right this
is a plan and it's a disastrous plan it
we've already said it is the uninvent of
America but would it work to keep the
the blue racket going it might and
that's a very frightening prospect you
know this strikes me what you just said
about what the what the Democratic Party
is becoming this sort of assortment of
loosely associated interest groups is
exactly what we used to say about the
Republican Party when you know when we
were coming of age in the 80s and 90s
that this was it didn't it didn't appear
to be or an organic grouping of people
of like mind or particularly like values
but rather you had you know the the
pro-life people and to a rights people
you know amendment to a rights people
and you know these very at the
evangelical Christians yes that didn't
particularly cohere and it sounds to me
like what we're seeing in part and I
think you know we saw this decline we
saw this decline beginning again in the
90s for Democrats again with with
Clinton with Bill Clinton a dqo hearing
of meaning within the Democratic Party
and instead a sort of pandering for
interest group votes right so if I can
put some flesh on those bones there's no
real reason that the party of business
should also be the party of gun rights
right that's that's not natural there's
no reason that the party of business
should be suspicious of Darwinism right
these this is a coalition of convenience
a political coalition and what you're
saying which I totally agree with is
that their once upon a time was a basic
thread that explained the Democratic
Party it was the interest of working
people
yeah right and that's and so I mean
people people who were suspicious from
the beginning of the Democrats could say
well you know what are the unions doing
there well nope working people you know
what what is environmental rights doing
there well we all
it's it's about a commonality of good
and purpose that we all need if we are
going to be able to live some standard
yeah and you know we you know maybe you
could tear that apart but it seemed to
have a thread through it that made good
sense and it was it was about working
people yeah it never made great sense
the point was there was always such a
big core working people do have
interests right they're constantly being
screwed by entities that want to freeze
them out of stuff having some political
party that represents their interests
makes sense and then you can say well
what are their other interests right and
that created a natural coalition which
it did evaporate when the Democratic
Party took up influence-peddling
full-time and part of what happened
frankly is that when these schools of
IDI these self-styled scholars who
really don't appear to be able to do any
kind of analysis that's worth the worth
the word analysis moved in and started
training the generations teachers what
they in part did with this with this
embrace of post of postmodernist and
even pseudo post modernists thought was
elevate the idea of white collar work
much of which is meaningless and
pointless and doesn't need to be done
and throughout the value of and the the
idea that there was virtue and honor in
blue collar work and in so doing they a
you know guaranteed that there are a lot
of people who had been voting Democratic
we're not going to anymore if you know
if if people working the trades are no
longer valued because this this post -
garbage coming out of schools of Ed is
now in the Democratic Party as well
which it clearly is some number of
people are going to say well screw that
I'm going to the other party but it it
also reminds us once again of something
that I and we have been saying for a
long time which is that for people who
literally do not do anything that is
physical in the world and therefore have
no thing that they do from which they
can get feedback which cannot be gamed
those people have an easier time fooling
themselves and
rest of the world about what their true
intentions are and whether or not
they're supposed solutions will work I
actually don't really want to hear from
someone who's who's got proposed
solutions if they can't demonstrate to
me that they can do something in the
physical world successfully and I was
actually I was walking around Oregon
City a week ago or so waiting well our
younger son was having an orthodontist
appointment and I passed by statue
outside the local courthouse I forgotten
the guy's name but he was some important
figure in Oregon City maybe one of the
first judges an important lawyer and
this the bust of him had all of those
things but the very first thing that it
had on the on the statue in terms of
what he did was welder and I hope I have
in this right I hope I have which trade
it was which all these other things were
but I come in as a Toby our son this
appointment I was waiting on after I
said you know isn't isn't that amazing
and wonderful that they chose to point
out first and maybe was blacksmith like
I can't remember you know that they
chose first and foremost to identify the
trade that he was skilled in before
pointing out the things that he did that
are why his bust is here you know if he
had just been a blacksmith or weld or
whatever it was that he was doing he
wouldn't have a statue in front of the
courthouse right yeah but I would argue
that had he not had that background in
the trade that he did he also wouldn't
have his bust in front in that
courthouse because he wouldn't have the
sense and the wisdom that those skills
gave him in order to do good in the
world later yeah an incredible amount of
what's true is also counterintuitive to
one level or another and the way you
discover that is through some system in
which what is counterintuitive you are
forced to it by the fact that the system
isn't listening to clever arguments it
just works or doesn't and so yes you and
I both have this sense that it is
fundamentally important before you start
deciding what should happen that you
have experience with some system that is
completely impervious to your cleverness
of speech and only responds to your
depth of
sucked mm-hmm so can we talk a little
bit about the downstream consequences of
this flow of bad ideas from schools of
Ed and other places into various
important roles in society that's do it
so Zach will you bring up the New York
Times book section/article that I gave
you so let me set this up don't see it
all right so I will just recap it then
there is yeah you don't know this is the
first I'm hearing about it
I don't remember what the article is
called
it was about the woman who shot Andy
Warhol and there is a fawning piece in
The New York Times book section here it
is okay Zach it's on my screen now if
you want put that up so the premise of
this piece is that this it's an open she
died
is that the idea she's gone okay um the
premise of the piece is that her work
has been overshadowed by the fact that
she shot Andy Warhol now I should say
she shot Andy Warhol multiple times
premeditated murder and or would have
been attempted murder he survived but
was desperately injured now the work
that this author at the New York Times
is claiming is overshadowed is a work in
which he advocates the killing of all
men
now many people took this to be ironic
apparently she insisted it was literal
so my point is it is impossible for this
woman who attempted to murder Andy
Warhol to have her high quality work
overshadowed if the point of that work
is actually perfectly consistent with
the murder that she attempted but from
the point of view of this author and by
author I mean the author of this pitch
away the obituary I actually don't think
it's in a [ __ ] way I think she's been
gone some time this is a it's it's in
obituaries oh this is I think an
obituary if it's an obituary if somebody
who died long ago and the New York Times
didn't cover them so anyway this woman's
manifesto called scum advocates the
destruction of apparently an acronym
that stands for where was it the Society
for cutting up men right Society for
cutting up men the author of the article
describes the fact that the scum
manifesto is apparently alive and well
in some women and Gender Studies classes
and departments at American universities
today so anyway so I'm only seeing this
for the first time here's a sentence in
the early part of this obut the
manifesto self published in 1967 reads
as satire the Solanas defendant is
serious this sounds exactly like we
don't really mean defund the police well
and in fact this is exactly what Ezra
Klein and and Sam Harris were fighting
about was that Ezra Klein swore that
when the New York Times published kill
all men that that was meant to be taken
ironically and the point is was it yeah
partially it's meant to be taken
ironically if you're gonna be a stickler
about how ugly a thought that is and
then if you're not going to say anything
then maybe it's not to be taken
ironically do you think that in Jonathan
Swift's era people any anyone thought
that he was serious I mean isn't it in
order to count as satire don't the vast
majority of people who read the thing
have to recognize it as satire actually
there should be some standard like that
we have lost the ability and I have as
my followers on Twitter know had to
hard-code a solution to this problem
because there's nothing I can say that's
so insane that people will understand me
not to be speaking seriously so I use
the emoji to do that but yeah yeah there
should be some standard about either
your satire is
complete failure or it isn't satire if
some fraction of the population takes it
as serious on yeah first read well it
also omits it's totally illegitimate if
the author themselves says it's serious
and other people are saying no no no she
she doesn't really mean it it's satire
well then well then no right actually
then no and in this case it turns out at
the very last line of the piece you'll
find out that maybe it was satire but
that the person the the author of the
scum manifesto acknowledged that maybe
it was satire that instead of actually
killing all men what she wanted to do I
think should be neutered or castrated so
they can't mess up any more women's
lives right so the point here is not
really about the author of this gun
manifesto or even of the author of this
late obituary it is about the fact that
at the New York Times this apparently
passes for journalism and it reports
that these ideas are not just something
wrong headed in the mind of one author
at the New York Times that they are
apparently now in Gender Studies classes
in American universities with no
apparent irony so that's where we are
that's the horizontal nasai dia has
obviously begun to take over
universities and the same people who are
saying white supremacy is everywhere are
also taking seriously the idea that we
should be thinking about castrating men
are killing them I don't I mean I guess
the only thing I take issue with there
is the idea that it's begun to take over
universities I mean you and I were
seeing this in the early nineties yeah
we were seeing nonsense not at this
level you know not not scum manifesto
level explicitly but really batshit
loony undefensible unscholarly on
analytical nonsense being trotted out as
if it made sense and this was before the
advent of filling the X Studies
departments right those those fields
didn't even exist yet yeah they started
to proliferate in the sort of the mid
and late 90s so I mean this is this is
the thing that people have been saying
to us since evergreen blow-up from
before even when we were having
conversations with people before
evergreen blue
for it was public I was like yeah but
it's isolated it won't spread it's not a
big deal and and of course it was
already spreading because those people
graduate and they don't stay on call it
on college campuses forever so on some
of them do and so as you've pointed out
for years now the people that we were
encountering in the 90s had a generation
of students that are now the professors
of today and so anyway the thing is
matured and developed because we have
given it a hibernaculum or I don't know
some place to to to wait out those years
in part I mean academics are so insular
and so you know always feeling so
overworked and you know that's it's easy
to laugh at but you know if you really
are trying to do good deep work
constantly having demands on you for
governance and sit on this meeting and
that committee is burdensome and so
scientists in particular and I think
artists also but really all good
academics do tend to as much as possible
ignore the stuff going on at the
university that doesn't seem to apply
directly to them unless they are
absolutely forced to by the demands of
their job you know you have to spend 25
percent of your time on governance so
you have to attend these eight meetings
a year and they do that and then they're
done and they just check it off and they
don't think more about it and so the
sort of ostrich head in the sand thing
is in part because you know when they
when someone pops their head up on some
island goes wait what is happening now
in terms of administrative bloat and
changes in policy with regard to who
gets graded how and what kinds of
departments are being created oh boy I
don't even know I'm just gonna go back
to my research and you know that is that
is part and then especially in the
sciences that's allowed by the admitted
the old fashioned administrators because
scientists are paying for the
universities largely through the through
the grants that they're getting right
the forty to eighty percent in overhead
that every NSF grant an NIH grant that
comes in goes directly to the University
well let's not hassle those those nice
lab scientists who need lots of
expensive machines and so need lots of
expensive grants and just let them do
what they do and don't bother them with
the fact that the universities being
taken over by a bunch of loons yes that
was six weeks ago
now so three years ago this matured
early at Evergreen and the we didn't
have departments but we had the
equivalent of the various theory and
Studies departments and they began
dictating terms to the sciences that is
and people like you and me you and I
stood up and the rest is history on that
front but the point is that thing has
now come to every other university and
those departments are now dictating
terms to the sciences they have the
administrators on board because I don't
know that administrators actually have
thoughts but to the extent that they
have something like them these people
are simply looking out for their own
well-being and so they'll feed anybody
to the Wolves that they have - including
now the sciences but it was happening
before well it was beginning to but my
point about the horizontal nosov this
revolution is it's like you had some
group of people that gathered until some
point and spoke to each other in some
way that was recognizable and then
suddenly on some day the recognition
Dawn's we actually now have the power
that we can take this body over and so
actually can we M maybe before we do
this can you find a it was too late to
get Zak a link but there's a new piece
in the Atlantic a short piece by Yasha
monk that Sam Harris tweeted out anyway
this piece is quite good I highly
recommend it and what it details yeah
that's it that top ones about firing the
incent okay not yet Zak so this piece
details three cases in which people have
recently been terminated from their
employment these are not people who are
in a good position to construct
something else to take care of their
needs three people who were fired who on
inspection of their story there's
nothing to it and some corporate entity
just decided to do the expedient thing
and kowtow to some mob that was claiming
they were guilty of something in one
case the guy apparently has three
quarters not white and his a hand
hanging out the window of his car and it
appeared to someone who later admitted
that he probably overreacted
if the guy was making an okay symbol
which of course okay symbol
are you kidding you got to read this oh
my god yeah it's it's quite frightened
but the point is okay these three make
the Atlantic the Atlantic which you know
has become Uncas is a voice of reason
yeah sure but the Atlantic is sometimes
as a voice of reason and sometimes isn't
as all these places are so will the
Atlantic topple and articles like this
stop showing up I would guess it will
just as the New York Times looks
appeared about ready to topple
completely into this madness okay so
actually we use AK I want to now say
we've got a problem in journalism that
we are aware of Matt Taibbi has done a
brilliant job covering what's going on
in journalism and he's detailed I think
six cases in which an effective coup is
underway in very important places right
you know the New York Times the
intercept it's happening all over the
place but my point is this horizontal
thing is going to be anywhere you look
so I came across something this week can
you put up the link I gave you that says
something like we see you well your
analogy I don't think it is an analogy
you're you're calling this sleeper cells
is apt that whether or not it was the
conscious intention of schools of Ed to
train teachers to indoctrinate children
and in some cases it clearly was
conscious and in some cases maybe it
wasn't those children have grown up
often drugged often helicoptered unable
to do anything real in the world and
they're being handed a prefab revolution
and of course they're on board of course
they're on board for one thing a lot of
the rhetoric sounds pretty good if you
don't look at it too closely and maybe
they're slated to get an upgrade in
lifestyle because they're on the
intersectional side that's going to reap
the benefits so what I have here is
something from apparently the theater
community in Atlanta and here dear white
American theater
we come together as a community of black
indigenous and people of color
so by POC it's a new acronym
theatre-makers in the legacy of August
Wilson's to ground on which I stand to
let you know exactly what the grant what
ground we stand on in the wake of the
nation's civic unrest so this goes on to
say so there is no entity called white
American theater they are addressing
everyone who is white who was in
American theatre is that the idea
yes I believe so I you know I can't
imagine that there would be anything
called white American theater that would
be extraordinarily archaic and offensive
and so in some sense this is the
description of a boogie man and the
boogie man is one in which theater has
been oppressing black people in some
transparent way on every stage at all
times and this is the claim that it has
been seen which is effectively very
close to an empirical client right this
is not an allegation this is a
description it's an eyewitness account
of something that can't possibly be
happening but anyway my point here isn't
about theater and it's not about Atlanta
it's about the fact that you wouldn't
know this was happening
except that if you tuned in to this
little world of Atlanta theater you
discover oh my goodness the coup is
happening right and well and I we heard
from a lot of people in theater after
evergreen blew up yeah we your inbox
blew up thousands and thousands of
emails and I went through many of them
and there were a tremendous number of
people writing in from theater now what
are the chances that people who go into
theater are particularly racist or
bigoted or unwilling to investigate
other narratives about what might be
going on right know that like this is
what art is is what art is for is
precisely about engaging with different
perspectives different ways of living
different historical periods different
places different ideologies different
demographics all of this this is what we
need narrative for and theater is a
particularly wonderful way
I mean you and I both enjoy live theater
quite a lot we've been going to we're
taking our children to live theater
multiple times a year for years now and
and we've been hearing a little bit from
people we actually know in a couple of
these theater companies but much more so
from a number of anonymous well people
who we don't know but who came to us
with their stories theater troupes seem
particularly prone to prostrate
themselves before this ridiculous false
set of accusations and gods when they
are actually doing some of the most
forward-thinking I can't use the word
anti-racist anymore but like actually
anti-racist it's a narrative work and
therefore the presentation of narrative
work is one of the places that we work
out the difficult nuances that's the
whole point of the exercise and so to
have something behind the scenes taking
place that erases all nuance and creates
totally phony narratives right is toxic
and we've seen this week a number of
cases in which you know in some animated
series some white actor was voicing a
character of color and they've now
stepped down so in those cases we can
say that whatever these are celebrities
they'll you know they've got plenty of
resources maybe it shouldn't have been a
white person along but my point is this
is now a threat the point is this is a
threat going forward right every time
you have a job opening you have to bend
over backwards to make sure that the
accusation that you've done anything
other than prioritised the voices of
people that you know have demographic
markers that you can spot you have to
make every effort to do that so the
point is yes this is a coup and some of
the people paying the price are
celebrities and maybe that's not all
that awful right I don't like it but the
point is if you're a celebrity
you've probably got resources but this
is going to the this is going to fall
down on the heads of thousands and
thousands of people who are depending on
you know a theatre is a difficult line
of work and if you are suddenly now
unable to get a job because your
demographic
markers don't slate you for one that's a
disaster furthermore it threatens all
narrative it threatens all of our
ability to hear stories that don't sound
like what we expect the idea I mean this
isn't I don't have an example from this
week but over the last few years we've
heard these many stories of okay so I
think it was Janine Cummings is her name
who wrote an American dirt she has maybe
a Puerto Rican grandmother I may be
getting some of the descriptions wrong I
didn't know we were gonna be talking
about this but her book tour was
canceled in her book almost canceled on
the basis that
how dare she write a book about a
middle-class Mexican woman and her son
running from the narcos through Mexico
and ultimately escaping to the US
because she is not herself Mexican
American nor has she herself escaped
from the narcos she had no right to
write this they you know that publisher
was obliged apparently to find instead
someone who wished to write a novel who
already lived that life well this is
misunderstanding you know everything but
you know what is fiction for one thing
but also if we are really in this
landscape where you cannot write from
the perspective of someone else we are
being asked to forgo all that is best
about humanity we I can I cannot omit I
I am NOT allowed to imagine myself into
your brain because let's see your mail
and you're Jewish and you know so many
other things that make you different for
me if we take that to its most obvious
extreme none of us can possibly imagine
the experience of anyone else and
therefore we are forbidden from writing
fiction . it is the it is the death of
fiction is the death of narrative we can
only write from and this and this is
what they say with regard to lived
experience you know the the the best
form of knowledge the only legitimate
form of knowledge I've even heard is
lived experience and that's that's the
end of science that's the end of
hypothetical deduction ISM that's the
end of analysis but it's also we've said
that many times it's also the end of
fiction in narrative it's the end we're
just doomed across the board it's the
end of empathy
and I would point out a example that
just pops to mind yeah if I'd known we
were headed here I would have looked up
the actor's name but the movie life is
beautiful I think was its name about a
Jewish father who tries to make life for
his son bearable in I believe it's
Auschwitz and the actor who plays the
main role was attempt to open Nene
roberta benigni yeah that's right
so you it's hard for me even to imagine
an outcry about the fact that you know
this this heartbreaking story acted so
beautifully by this actor that he didn't
happen to be Jewish is irrelevant and
maybe it's even a triumph in some sense
because he you know he really evokes it
and so yes isn't this exactly what we
want for other people to be able to
understand not only our joys but our
pain this this is what we are looking
for this is the connection that is what
is human yeah and we are being told how
dare you try to understand me you cannot
you shall not you will not we will
threaten you yeah until you fall into
line with all of these other things but
do not dare try to imagine that you can
report on what it is to be me okay now
add a dash of Orwell okay hey Zack can
you bring up the the other theater boy
I've forgotten what I called the link
that I sent you you want me to try to
find out what is it mm go through them
yep great yep
Town Hall for racial reckoning this
looks like the Atlanta one can you a
large us an even large this a little bit
yes no if you can't I can read it okay
if you want me to read it out loud yeah
you want to start reading yeah Town Hall
for racial reckoning our community is
experiencing a reckoning the global
effects of the pandemic and now the
civil unrest in our communities are
highlighting the disparities between
white lives and the lives of people of
color especially black people a seismic
shifting of the status quo is
threatening to rock the foundation upon
which so many theaters in this community
have built their legacies when we were
able to make theater again we cannot
return to quote business as usual and
quote we cannot return to theater
companies that will not acknowledge and
respect the voices of the by POC
community in an effort to make sure
those voices are heard the Coalition for
racial equity in Atlanta theater CRE 80
and inclusion diversity equity in the
arts Atlanta idea Atlanta have partnered
to host a three night virtual town hall
okay so can you scroll up okay you can
sign up to attend here's a list of the
theaters that are going to participate
so I get go down and can you click rules
of engagement yeah on the left now they
left that was press release there we go
rules of engagement now the basic idea
and these rules of engagement I will
spare you all of the detail but the
basic rules are certain people are
empowered to speak about the horrors in
the Atlanta theatre community screw up
just a little bit Zack stop we ask that
all speakers speak only to their own
personal experience it may cause further
trauma to speak of someone else's
experience if they are not yet ready the
administrators are told it is they will
not be given an opportunity to speak and
they are instructed that they must
maintain they must have their cameras on
at all times okay they are not allowed
to turn off their cameras so
they are going to sit and they are going
to listen to stories of lived experience
they will not be empowered to respond in
any way and they must do so with the
cameras on so that their expressions
will be constantly available for all who
attend as witnesses a witness is a by
Parker alley theater make or ally
sorry theater maker who wishes to be
present support we ask that you remain
respectful throughout the evening fair
enough please try and limit extraneous
movement during the process eg driving
or washing driving or washing dishes yes
can you scroll up and find the where
cameras will be on stop it there it is
at the very bottom okay now that's all
attendees there's also the
administrators are being specifically
instructed that they must have their
cameras on at all time and I can't I
don't see where it is but anyway this is
absolutely Orwellian it is a twist on
struggle sessions it is struggle
sessions in theatres all of the dangers
that you and I were just talking about
flow from this rather directly but again
the point really isn't about theatre the
point is we've seen this up close and
personal in colleges and universities
we've seen it in schools of IDI we've
seen it in in journalism and it is
spreading at a rapid rate we're seeing
the Democratic Party play ball with this
thing at the highest possible levels and
what is the natural remedy so my point
would be look you've got natural
remedies this is completely insane
people are being fired for things that
they never did they're being fired for
completely symbolic reasons that's not
actually legally acceptable right but
you would have to go to a court to
establish that you had been harmed this
is also going to be in every single
court right so it is getting harder to
imagine that a a white plaintiff could
prevail in such a case if they you know
if the juries and judges are sensitive
to the fact that they may be next to be
portrayed as somehow whipe supremacists
so this is it this is an Orwellian
nightmare
all of the natural remedies if the court
fails what's supposed to protect you
well journalism the fact of the court
having failed might be reported and
people might say oh my goodness what's
going on in the court system how did it
get so broken well that's going to be
gone too there's no remedy left and that
is a cruelly frightening fact we are we
are watching a horizontal revolution and
frankly I don't know where it isn't I
don't know where it isn't either I think
the it's harder to have outposts now in
part because social media gets
everywhere those who are self-employed
need probably to fall in line lest they
not get business it looks to me like
those people who actually do physical
things are more immune but those
businesses too will be targeted it looks
to me you know if I just take say you
know within a supermarket the people
cutting up meat the butchers seem the
the most the least woke and the most
immune to this nonsense of all of the
grocery workers that that I see but I
again I think that those people who are
so-called blue-collar workers are less
likely to succumb to the mind virus
itself but that doesn't save them from
the organization they work for feeling
like it has to succumb lest it be
canceled so to make sure that we do not
get carried away here
Chloe Valerie took me to task on Twitter
gently as she always does but she said
we should be careful there are multiple
movements responding to her that I don't
see multiple movements I see factions
but I don't see multiple movements I see
a coalition but anyway the question here
is this I would love to think that there
are multiple movements that are actually
vying for narrative here because
actually were a movement that made sense
to emerge from this by virtue of those
who had
superior understanding and capacity to
reason were to triumph that would be
great
I see no possibility of it happening
because the mechanism by which the
movement figures out what it stands for
barely exists even black lives matters
as a central organisations but anytime
you point to that central organization
people say oh but that's not black live
matter that that's that's one entity
there are other manifestations and so
without leadership that is recognized by
the movement there's no one to negotiate
with there's no one to reason with
there's no one to reign in the abuses
and because of that it is certain to be
a disaster and it is certain to cause
the backlash on the other side which
will be every bit as ugly yeah no I I
think that's right and I don't know it's
hard to know exactly what movements
versus factions means in terms of the
distinction but to return very briefly
to a point that we spent a fair bit of
time on last time with regard to what
what is trans ideology and trans rights
activists what doing so prominently in
the black lives matter movement when
that would seem to be antithetical to
their main main principle so I've just
got three images to show not quite sac
that suggests that at both the top of
social media and in politics we are
already seeing a change in messaging
from black lives matter to black trans
lives matter so here is that can you put
up my screen here's the official Twitter
account as of yesterday has changed its
bio to read black queer lives matter
black trans lives matter oh by the way
third hashtag black lives matter
so wait let's just stop the process that
that is the official Twitter account
that is the official Twitter account
that is the bio of the official Twitter
account okay the official Twitter
account also tweeted this and this is on
a billboard
so they retweeted quote tweeted I guess
black trans lives mattered that's all
that's the tweet okay and then the mayor
of Seattle who's doing such a brilliant
job with chap jaws judge as Jeff I can
never pronounce a right had who I guess
I have not looked into her but I guess
she may be lesbian herself even not that
that matters at all except check this
out she tweeted this pride we can
celebrate how far we've come but we must
recognize how far we have to go we
cannot rest until our trans community
particularly trans women of color have
full freedoms and you don't have to fear
hate violence or persecution hashtag
pride particularly trans women of color
particularly trans women of color yeah
it's this pride let's focus on natal men
let's do that yeah put aside the racial
the the racial thing I mean none of us
are supposed to be allowed to do that
right now but I kind of don't even want
to go there
right why is everyone feeling not just
empowered but forced to focus on men who
have declared themselves women often
without any other evidence to support
the idea that they are and saying that
that is the new face of progressivism
and enlightenment you can take it down
so let's let's do this another way
because undoubtedly there are black
trans black trans women which is to say
people born male who have transitioned
to female undoubtedly that's a
demographic however the category
includes any presumably any black man
who wants to say that he is now a woman
so that is a loophole if this is the
pinnacle of what we must be fighting for
then any black man can opt into it which
is a frightening prospect and again I
don't think we know
meaning of what's going on but it is
conspicuous that evergreens meltdown was
led by three black trans women it is to
say people born male transitioned to
female who led the collapse of our
College and the attack on us so
something is going on here the fact that
there was a major demonstration in New
York that this you know the George Floyd
rallies were continuing a pace and then
black transness was the focus of the
second eruption of rallies why is this
our second priority this at most it's a
tiny demographic and I'd be hard-pressed
to tell you what the what the concerns
are what it is like to be in that
category but nonetheless there's
something conspicuous about the fact
that this is like the flagship identity
of this movement so to Khloe's point
Chloe Valerie's point there is something
going on
largely behind the scenes that is one to
your point maybe one faction within this
larger movement or maybe a wholly
distinct movement that is cloaking
itself in the mainstream black lives
matter movement and pretending to be
that same thing and thus getting in that
is very explicitly about this hyper
niche demographic that is growing such
that it's got to be the fairly rare
person at least living on the coasts at
this point and probably in any city who
is not has not run into the idea of
trans lives mattering in the last few
weeks and this is this is not a
demographic that warrants such
remarkable attention otherwise so maybe
maybe we should stop that for now return
to this another time so there's a lot
more to say yeah there's a lot there's a
lot to be said but I think the the fact
that at some level the intersectional
logic which was never coherent to begin
with nonetheless effectively specifies
that the if
if this movement is really about and the
last shall be first and the first shall
be last then the top of the pyramid will
be black trans women by virtue of the
fact that they have opted into two
categories that is to say that these are
people who have opted into the protected
category trans and the protected
category woman which is a remarkable
feat yeah if you can opt in to the top
of the new oppressors lots of people
will pop some people will it's it you
know depending on what life you're
living maybe that's a sweet deal all
right perhaps it is time for us to take
a break and then to come back and answer
your super chat questions in the second
live stream the link will be in the
description so we will we'll start by
answering super chat questions that came
in on this live stream I'm prioritizing
by monetary value we had almost a
hundred questions last time we got to
maybe a quarter of them but you know
that we appreciate the support very much
and the questions and there are many
that are good that we don't get to but
we of course cannot cannot get to them
all to that point we will be doing our
first private Q&A tomorrow at 11:00
which you will get a link to if you join
our Dark Horse membership over at my
patreon at the five-dollar level are up
we've already got so many questions from
people who signed up at the higher tier
that we probably can't take any more
questions for tomorrow we've already got
more than we can handle but anyone who
signs up for that before 11:00 tomorrow
will have access to the link if they
want to join us for another Q&A tomorrow
all right
so please like subscribe comment and
maybe most importantly share if you
think others should see it and we will
be back in 15 or so minutes until then
be well
you
[Music]